a couple things what one is they should
really they should really figure out if
this is something that they really want
to do at this point in time you know I
think obviously I'm in the business
school of business and I think it's
great but it's not great for everybody
there are some people who you know don't
it's not going to fit them very well for
what they what they want to do in life
so I I would say that that's the first
thing is to really do your homework to
decide G is an MBA degree going to get
me where I want to go second thing I
would say is that the difference between
schools even the ones that might be
frequently rated the same or mentioned
in the same kind of articles the
difference among them is phenomenal you
know I myself I've been at the
university of chicago harvard business
school and the Ross School of Business
those three places even though we all
grant the same thing at the end an MBA
totally different set of experiences
totally different set of skills that you
are going to have when you come out so
in terms of assessing which one are
which one of the many options that that
you're going to have is best for you
really requires you to be very
self-aware and understand what your
skills are which one of those you want
to further which ones I where are your
deficiencies can you leave those
deficiencies as deficiencies which you
sometimes can do or do you have to
remedy them and then really studying the
the schools in terms of how is each one
going to progress you on your your
individual paths and you know I I know
all of us is the deans of the major
schools what we really try to do is be
articulate as we can about what we can
do so that somebody doesn't wind up at
our place by mistake and I would much
you know if you want to be a quant
superstar I'd much rather tell you that
GD University of Chicago based on my
experience there is probably better at
that than that any school I know and if
you really want to develop general
management skills from an action based
learning perspective that's what we
think we do better than
anybody else so so rather than looking
at any one of the ratings agencies and
thinking that number four is much
different from number six to really look
very closely at at what one of these
very different programs is going to do
for you as an individual
no I couldn't I I will other than
obviously the Ross Ross School of
Business but you know I as I said in
answer to your earlier question about
what advice would I give to somebody
going to an MBA program it's really
these the schools are really so
different from one another you have to
do your homework and and I sometimes
tell tell students that you know I have
a 31 year old daughter who actually got
a bachelor's degree in educational
policy rather than in an MBA but that's
that's another story but I said you know
there are there are lots of great
schools in the United States and around
the world that I would have been
delighted to see my daughter go to about
25 different places and so it's really
all an individual fit for yourself and
as I say I think there are terrific
schools and each one is different in
their own way and I think if you can
really do your homework on them you'll
find one that really works for you